Twitter has had a lot of layoffs more
than half of layoffs Mass layoffs
yes tech companies are already gearing
up for recession and the best way that
they deal with recession is to cut jobs
Twitter had a total of 7 500 employees
at the end of 2021 but after acquiring
Twitter Elon Musk would have viciously
lay off the workforce shrinking it to
just 1300 employees out of which only
550 were full-time Engineers with such a
purge you were to think that outages
become commonplace bugs and glitches
become a normality and that the
infrastructure of the company would
collapse from within but as far as we
can tell Twitter is still completely
operational I mean as an average user
you wouldn't even know that such a
massive change unfolded it on the back
end not only has Twitter remained
operational but that they've even been
able to roll out some new features like
Twitter blue but this doesn't make sense
if 1300 employees are able to keep
Twitter functional and even launch new
features why in the world did Twitter
have a 7 500 employees just six months
ago this might seem like a Twitter
specific question at first glance but
when you zoom out you'll realize that
this same question applies to virtually
every tech company Facebook has a total
of 86 000 employees Google has a total
of 190 000 employees and the apple has a
total of 164 000 employees now of course
not all of these employees are software
Engineers but a substantial portion of
them are as in 30 to 50 percent and even
more of them are Tech workers involved
in program management it and solutions
architecting it's not just these big fan
companies either the same question
applies to well-known startups as well
Robinhood 3 800 employees Airbnb 6800
employees Uber 33 000 employees I mean
why in the world does Uber needed 33 000
employees this becomes even more
confusing when you consider that most of
the core services for all of these
companies are already built out and
functional for years if not decades I
mean modern software engine years at
Google aren't going to be writing search
algorithms from scratch and software
engineers at Instagram aren't going to
be creating messaging infrastructure
from scratch now of course many of these
software Engineers have been getting
laid off in recent times Google laid off
12 000 people Facebook laid off 21 000
people and you know all those startups
that we were talking about well most of
them have laid off 40 to 50 percent of
their Workforce but this simply furthers
The Narrative that these companies are
able to get away with far smaller
workforces so why exactly did they have
so many software engineers in the first
place and what exactly were all of them
even doing
foreign
sense would lead you to believe that
running these companies simply requires
such a large Workforce but that's not
exactly true well coding may seem
intimidating and difficult from an
outside perspective the truth is that
most coding projects are actually pretty
straightforward creating an app like
Instagram or Airbnb isn't actually that
hard Airbnb for example could be created
by a single developer and a single ux
designer within 16 weeks and you don't
even have to Outsource the labor to
cheap developers overseas you can pay
the developer five thousand dollars
every week and the ux designer fifty
dollars per hour and it would still only
cost 82 000 but you don't even have to
look that far instead you can look back
many of the tech apps and services that
we use on a daily basis were initially
completely developed by less than five
people the initial WhatsApp was created
by a Russian developer from
rentacoder.com the initial Airbnb
website was created by three roommates
the initial Uber app was created by
three friends and the initial version of
Twitter was created by just Dorsey and a
contractor now of course as you grow you
wouldn't want to rely on less than five
developers you would want developers
checking each other's work developers
were focused on user retention
developers were focused on onboarding
developers who are focused on a b
testing developers were focused on
backend engineering and so on you would
also want to program managers who are
leading each of these efforts and a CTO
who can set company-wide goals and
timelines but none of this takes tens of
thousands of employees more
realistically it would take hundreds of
employees and if you want to be generous
you can call it a thousand employees
similar to what Twitter has right now
most companies that didn't indeed start
off this way but somewhere along the
line they started hiring far past their
needs take Facebook for example at the
end of 2014 they had a total of 9 200
employees by this point Facebook had
already been around for over 10 years
and they owned all three of their main
platforms Facebook WhatsApp and
Instagram the core functionality of
these Services were complete and the
only tasks ahead were optimization and
scaling this isn't to say that these
tasks are easy but Lance also
questionable if it warranted a 9x
increase in headcount over the next
several years a similar story can be
seen at Google as well back in 2014
Google had a total of 54 000 employees
by this point Google already had all of
their money making Services set up and
they're performing well and they had a
market cap as high as 400 billion
dollars you would think that Google
could cut back on hiring and simply let
time do its magic but instead Google
would go ahead and increase their head
count to nearly 200 000 so if it's not
an intrinsic need that's pushing these
companies to hire more what is
one of the main reasons that these
companies hire so many people is simply
because they can this might sound a bit
anti-climactic but it's true virtually
all of the companies that we've
discussed so far are extraordinarily
profitable on their own or they have
infinite Venture Capital money at first
these companies do the sensible thing
with all this money they build up cash
reserves they diversify into new
businesses and they solidify their user
base and the brand image but eventually
they run out of things to do as they
simply reach Market saturation
traditionally this is when a company
would chill out and to pay dividends but
these are tech companies that we're
talking about traditional oil consumer
and Industrial Giants take 50 70 100
years to get to this point so the
transition the dividends feels more
natural these tech companies however
often get to this point within 5 10 20
years pretty soon this leads to some
pretty weird hiring Habits Like hiring
with no intention this might sound
confusing but this is literally what
happens at a normal company if your team
needs a new person your manager would
have probably put in a request with HR
HR would then turn around and put up a
job posting and leave it up for a month
or so to attract a sufficient number of
candidates from there HR would pass on
the most promising candidates to your
manager who would then interview these
people and to choose the best one this
is how a normal sensible company hires
but at most tech companies it's the
exact opposite in fact the needs of
specific teams is mostly irrelevant
instead these companies have generic job
listings like software engineer and
program manager that are up forever and
and not until candidates passed the
arduous hiring bar that Google even
thinks about where to place them this
often results in candidates passing the
hiring bar but then getting it
infinitely stuck in the team matching
phase why does Google do this you ask
well if philosophy is basically we have
a crap ton of money so let's just hire
the best people and we can worry about
giving them something to do later for
obvious reasons this leads to a pretty
bloated Workforce and that team
switching policies have just made this
even worse in traditional companies it's
relatively hard to switch teams the
reason for this is that you were hired
to do a specific job so if you switch to
another team they now have to find
someone to do your old job at many tech
companies though you weren't hired to do
a job you were Simply Hired based on
your skills and general knowledge so
they have some pretty lenient team
switching policies which candidates
naturally tend to leverage you see over
time candidates have come to realize
that if they waste too much time in team
matching they might not get a job at the
company despite passing the hiring bar
so it's in their best interest to join
the first team they can and just switch
to the team they really want 6 or 12
months down the line well this is clever
it also leads to a twofold issue first
of all it's not clear how useful they
will be during the first 6 or 12 months
in the first team and secondly it's
likely that most Google and Facebook
hopefuls have these same dream teams in
mind leading to certain teams becoming
even more bloated but despite all this
these companies still continue hiring it
because they're chasing an infinite
growth
why do tech companies have so many
employees well the answer is that they
not only over hire but most of these
employees end up working on things that
will never see the light of day things
like weather balloons that are supposed
to increase internet connectivity
underwater cameras for ocean Farmers AI
That's supposed to increase agriculture
light that can enable wireless
connections these are all projects that
Google is working on right now and that
those are just a few of the public ones
who knows how many more projects Google
has behind the scenes and as for
Facebook do I even have to say anything
about the metaverse the metaverse is
just one example though several years
ago Facebook was pouring substantial
resources into building drone internet
and who could forget Google Glass the
reality is that most of these moonshot
projects don't end up going anywhere but
they do end up requiring a lot of
employees and the resources this doesn't
just apply to moonshot ideas either most
projects relating to even successful
projects like Chrome and YouTube Don't
generate any Roi for example if you use
Chrome you may have noticed that Google
has recently been experimenting with the
UI of downloads instead of having the
download shelf on the bottom they're
experimenting with a downloaded icon on
the top right but it's hard to say if it
will actually increase Google's revenue
or profit in any meaningful way it
probably did however keep several
Engineers busy for several weeks but if
the ROI isn't there why do these
companies continue pursuing these
projects well the answer is that they're
chasing endless growth they've exhausted
most of the obvious Avenues so all they
can do now is experiment with these out
their ideas and optimize the UI to the
absolute Max most users will never spot
these changes or use these new products
or make the company any extra money but
that doesn't mean that these companies
will stop trying after all the end of
the quarter is always around the corner
and they want to please shareholders
in the end the harsh reality is that
most tech companies don't need it
anywhere near as many employees as they
have if they were just trying to
maintain their platforms they could get
away with 20 to 30 of their Workforce
but they're not just trying to maintain
their platforms they're trying to add
another 10 billion or another trillion
onto their market cap and they're
willing to over hire tens of thousands
of employees burn up billions of dollars
and it waste tens of millions of
man-hours in hopes that they might find
the next Chrome or the next iPhone or
the next Instagram so far this hasn't
exactly worked out some parts of the
metaverse have 38 users we have yet to
see the Apple car or the apple of your
headset or the Apple Air glasses or
whatever and Google's most successful
moonshot idea waymo is still somehow
eons behind Tesla none of this mattered
though these companies had money and
they were gonna try to Brute Force
creativity Innovation and a market need
but for the first time these companies
are starting to see their money go down
and these projects take a toll on their
Core Business and it's only now that
these companies are starting to realize
that they're inside and over hiring
nightmare doesn't really matter for the
companies though as it's the employees
that have to deal with a 20 30 40 50
reduction in the workforce and that's
the harsh reality of the tech industry
right now do you think over hiring is
reasonable comment that down below also
drop a like if you wish that employees
weren't the ones getting the short end
of the stick and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community
together ideas and consider subscribing
to see more questions and logically
answered but until then I'm Hari nosy
guys on the next one
[Music]